This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Neil Young is a rare artist. He's had big commercial success while also enjoying credibility as a musician's musician. He's also insanely prolific. Young has released dozens of albums. It's hard to pick a favorite Neil Young song, but I'm a simple man and I think mine is probably Harvest Moon. Look, there are a lot of great choices.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。尼尔·杨是一位罕见的艺术家。他在商业上获得了巨大的成功，同时作为“音乐家中的音乐家”也备受认可。而且他极其高产。杨发行了数十张专辑。很难挑出一首最喜欢的尼尔·杨的歌，但我是一个简单的人，我想我最喜欢的可能是《Harvest Moon》。听着，有很多伟大的选择。
I think I'm more of a Heart of Gold guy myself. But Neil Young is not just some legend of classic rock. Best producer Chris Berube. There is a whole other side of Neil Young's career. His bizarre experimental side. There's the Neil Young who made a divisive electronic music album. Or the Neil Young who designs model train sets. Neil Young even directed a very confusing sci-fi movie in the 80s starring Devo.
我本人可能更偏爱《Heart of Gold》。但尼尔·杨不仅仅是经典摇滚的某种传奇。制作人克里斯·贝鲁比。尼尔·杨的职业生涯还有完全不同的一面。他那离奇的实验性的一面。有那个制作了一张备受争议的电子音乐专辑的尼尔·杨。或者那个设计模型火车套装的尼尔·杨。在上世纪80年代，尼尔·杨甚至执导了一部由Devo主演、非常令人困惑的科幻电影。
It's called Human Highway. Good gas! Oh, it's bird gas! It's the best! You make it yourself? Nah, it comes from birds! Human Highway, man. It's come from birds. Human Highway, man, it's a weird one. But perhaps the biggest swing came about four decades into his career when Neil Young decided
这部电影叫《人类高速公路》。好汽油！哦，这是鸟类的汽油！太棒了！你自己做的？不，这是从鸟身上弄来的！《人类高速公路》，老兄。这是从鸟身上弄来的。《人类高速公路》，老兄，这部片子真诡异。但也许他职业生涯中最大的一次大胆尝试发生在他人生的第四个十年，当时尼尔·杨决定
to make his own digital music player, which he called the Pono. You don't like the iTunes and the iPod and that kind of stuff. You got this thing called Pono, which is your own music player. Well, because it's not that I don't like it. It's just that I can't play what I do. The Pono was meant to be a competitor to the iPod. The Pono was a portable digital music player. But unlike the iPod, it had a long, triangular, candy bar-esque shape.
制作他自己的数字音乐播放器，他将其命名为 Pono。你既不喜欢 iTunes、iPod 这类东西。你搞了这个叫 Pono 的东西，也就是你自己的音乐播放器。嗯，因为倒不是说我不喜欢它。只是我没法播放我创作的东西。Pono 旨在成为 iPod 的竞争对手。Pono 是一款便携式数字音乐播放器。但与 iPod 不同的是，它有一个长长的、三角形的、类似巧克力棒的外形。
It's not a... It looks like a Toblerone. It's not. It does taste... What does this do? For your ears, it's it looks like a Toblerone. It's not. It does taste. For your ears, it's even better than a Toblerone. Really? Yes, it sounds. You ever jammed a Toblerone in your ear, my friend? Neil Young unleashed the Pono in 2015 with a lot of media coverage and endorsements from famous musicians like
这不是一个……它看起来像个三角巧克力。它不是。它确实尝起来……这玩意儿是干嘛用的？为了你的耳朵，它……它看起来像个三角巧克力。它不是。它确实尝起来。为了你的耳朵，它甚至比三角巧克力还要好。真的吗？是的，它听起来。老兄，你有没有把一块三角巧克力塞进过耳朵里？尼尔·杨在 2015 年推出了 Pono，获得了大量媒体报道，并得到了许多著名音乐人的背书，比如
Bruce Springsteen and Tom Petty. But the Toblerone-esque music player was confusing to a lot of potential consumers. Most people just didn't understand why it was necessary to replace their iPods with another device that retailed for about $400. Even Neil Young's fans did not totally get it.
布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和汤姆·佩蒂。但这款类似三角巧克力的音乐播放器让许多潜在消费者感到困惑。大多数人根本不明白，为什么非得用另一款零售价约 400 美元的设备来取代他们的 iPod。就连尼尔·杨的粉丝也没有完全理解它。
My initial reaction to it was really just sort of like, eh, let's see, I was 25 when it came out. I didn't have a lot of expendable income at that point. I wasn't in the market for something to replace my iPod. That's Nate Rogers, a writer and a music critic who wrote about Pono for the website Stereogum earlier this year. Nate also happens to be a Neil Young superfan. I have a Neil Young, a picture of Neil Young on the wall in here that I've been looking at. I'm sitting directly across from 1979. It's Russ Never Sleeps tour. He's really
我对它的最初反应其实就是那种，“呃，走着瞧吧”。它刚问世时我才 25 岁。当时我没有什么可支配收入。我并没有打算买什么东西来取代我的 iPod。说话的是内特·罗杰斯，他是一位作家兼乐评人，今年早些时候曾在 Stereogum 网站上撰文谈论 Pono碰巧也是尼尔·杨的超级粉丝。我这儿的墙上就挂着一张尼尔·杨的照片，我一直看着它。我正对着 1979 年的它。那是他“Rusty Never Sleeps”巡演时的照片。他真的
rocking out with Crazy Horse, looks happy. If you've never heard of Pono before, that's because it came and went in a few short years, and at the time many critics dismissed Pono as a celebrity vanity project. But reading Nate Rogers' piece made me wonder if we were wrong about Pono, because Nate's article is actually headlined, what if we were wrong about Pono? Like maybe this awkward yellow triangular music player was actually a noble project. One we just weren't ready for. In the early 2010s, Neil Young was enjoying something of a career resurgence.
在和“疯马”乐队一起纵情摇滚，看起来很开心。如果你以前从未听说过 Pono，那是因为它仅仅存在了短短几年便昙花一现，当时许多评论家将 Pono 斥为名人的虚荣项目。但读了内特·罗杰斯的文章后，我开始怀疑我们是不是对 Pono 有所误解，因为内特的文章标题其实是：如果我们错怪了 Pono 会怎么样？就像也许这个尴尬的黄色三角形音乐播放器其实是一个崇高的项目。一个我们只是还没准备好接受的项目。在 2010 年代初期，尼尔·杨的职业生涯迎来了某种复苏。
He was playing shows across North America with his band Crazy Horse, and he was getting some of the best reviews of his career. But in interviews, Neil seemed upset, almost angry. He told journalists he was unhappy with the rise of digital downloads and that he didn't want to listen to songs on a computer. In fact, in one interview, Neil Young claimed he hadn't listened to music for over 15 years. I don't know how it's possible to not listen to music for 15 years, even if you're not a musician, so I don't really know what Neil was talking about there. I feel like he meant to say
他带着他的“疯马”乐队在北美各地巡演，并收获了他职业生涯中一些最好的评价。但在采访中，尼尔看起来很沮丧，甚至有点生气。他告诉记者，他对数字下载的兴起感到不满，他不想在电脑上听歌。事实上，在一次采访中，尼尔·杨声称他已经有 15 年多没听过音乐了。我不知道一个人怎么可能 15 年不听音乐，哪怕你不是音乐家，所以其实我也不太懂尼尔当时在说什么。我觉得他本想说
like I haven't listened to digital music in 15 years but he did say that so whatever maybe he did. Neil is an interesting person. Um love him. You're probably thinking this all sounds like typical old guy back in my day stuff was better kind of crankiness. And to be fair, yes, okay, maybe it's a little bit of that. But Neil Young actually had a good reason for boycotting digital music. According to Young, digitized music just sounded wrong. The origin of the Pono is that Neil Young thinks that digital music destroyed music quality in general. When Neil got his start in the 60s, everybody was listening to music on vinyl. Today, of course,
“我过去 15 年没听过数字音乐”，但他确实是那么说的，所以管他呢，也许他真的没听过。尼尔是个有趣的人。嗯，爱死他了。你可能觉得这听起来全都是那种典型的“老家伙说过去我那会儿的东西更好”的牢骚。平心而论，好吧，也许确实有一点这种成分。但尼尔·杨抵制数字音乐其实是有充分理由的。在杨看来，数字化音乐听起来就是不对劲。Pono 的起源在于尼尔·杨认为数字音乐整体上毁了音乐质量。当尼尔在 60 年代出道时，所有人都是在黑胶唱片上听音乐的。当然，今天
lots of folks love vinyl, but vinyl records were delicate and not super mobile. So in the 80s and 90s, vinyl was pushed out by new formats like cassette tapes and CDs. Cassettes were portable and handy. You could pop one of those bad boys into your Walkman or the console of your Dodge Neon and hit the road. But in the 90s, cassettes lost the format wars to CDs, which were slim and futuristic. They were just as portable as cassettes, but sounded much better. They didn't wear out or scratch as easily as vinyl, and they were free of the noise that plagued analog formats. But to people like Neil Young, there was something lost with the rise of CDs. A warmth. And MP3s? Well, that's where things started to get a whole lot worse.
许多人仍然热爱黑胶唱片，但黑胶唱片很脆弱，而且很不方便携带。所以在 80 和 90 年代，黑胶唱片被盒式磁带和 CD 等新格式挤出了市场。磁带便携又实用。你可以把其中一个坏小子塞进你的随身听或道奇霓虹汽车音响里，然后上路。但在 90 年代，磁带在格式大战中输给了 CD，后者轻薄且充满未来感。它们和磁带一样便携，但听起来要好得多。它们不像黑胶唱片那样容易磨损或刮花，而且也没有困扰模拟格式的噪音。但在尼尔·杨这样的人看来，随着 CD 的兴起，有些东西丢失了。那就是温暖感。至于 MP3 呢？好吧，事情就是从这里开始变得越来越糟的。
Because of something called compression. Basically, to fit a lot of songs onto a hard drive or an iPod, the files had to be pretty small, which means they had to be compressed or squeezed down in a way that reduces the quality of the music you're listening to. I guess the term is probably appropriately decimated. Maybe a tenth of that CD makes it onto an mp3 file. A way of measuring sound quality on a digital music file is in kilobits per second. A music file on a CD has about 1400 kilobits of information per second.
因为一种叫做压缩的技术。基本上，为了把大量的歌曲塞进硬盘或 iPod 里，文件必须非常小，这意味着它们必须经过压缩或挤压，而这会降低你所听音乐的质量。我想这个词大概可以恰如其分地称为“摧毁”。也许那张 CD 十分之的音质才勉强做成了一个 MP3 文件。衡量数字音乐文件音质的一种方法是“千比特每秒”。CD 上的音乐文件每秒包含约 1400 千比特的信息。
In a streaming mp3, that number goes down to about 96. It's shocking, honestly. It's very significant. It's shocking, honestly. It's very significant. It's hard to explain what gets lost when you do that much compression on an audio file. An mp3 of a song and a vinyl record might sound pretty similar to untrained ears, but to trained ears, there's a real difference. You know, a sense of ease to the sound. And that's going to be subjective and individual. But nevertheless, you know, if you listen to mp3s seriously, your attention wanders. John Atkinson is the former editor of Stereophile magazine. He says that with mp3s, listeners
而在流媒体 MP3 中，这个数字下降到了大约 96。老实说，这太令人震惊了。这非常显著。老实说，这太令人震惊了。这非常显著。很难向别人解释，当你对音频文件进行如此程度的压缩时，究竟会失去什么。对于未经训练的耳朵来说，一首歌的 MP3 和黑胶唱片听起来可能差不太多，但对于受过训练的耳朵来说，有着真正的区别。你知道的，声音有一种轻松感。这主观且因人而异。但尽管如此，你知道的，如果你认真听 MP3，你的注意力就会不集中。约翰·阿特金森是《Stereophile》杂志的前主编。他说，对于 MP3，听众
actually lose something pretty fundamental. Any transience in the music, you know, symbol crashes, any transience in the music, you know, cymbal crashes, beats, drums. So what was a clean hit on a drum now becomes more of a bwuh on a drum. So if you listen to low-res MP3s, you start to aware that the sense of rhythm has been degraded. You're missing a lot of the harmonics when you strum a guitar or hit a piano key. You hear one note, but you also hear a whole series of harmonics and notes that trail off. That's Phil Baker.
实际上失去了一些非常基础的东西。音乐中的任何瞬态，你知道的，镲片撞击声，音乐中的任何瞬态，你知道的，镲片撞击声、节拍、鼓声。所以原本在鼓上干净利落的一击，现在在鼓上听起来更像是一个“布乌”的声音。因此，如果你听低分辨率的 MP3，你就会开始意识到节奏感已经退化了。当你弹奏吉他或敲击钢琴键时，你会错失许多泛音。你听到了一个音符，但你也听到了整串逐渐减弱的泛音和音符。那是菲尔·贝克。
He worked as the product manager for Pono starting in 2012. When you strum a guitar string, it's not just boom, it's ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba. So all those other things are lost, or a good number of them are lost, because it's just truncates. It doesn't have the ability to play back that fine detail. There are a lot of subtleties. For many people that's fine. They hear music, they're used
从 2012 年开始，他担任 Pono 的产品经理。当你拨动吉他弦时，它不只是“砰”的一声，而是“叭叭叭叭叭叭叭叭”。所以所有这些其他的细节都丢失了，或者其中很大一部分都丢失了，因为它只是被截断了。它没有能力播放出那么细致的细节。里面有很多微妙之处。对许多人来说，这没关系。他们听到音乐，他们习惯了
to listening to radio, whether it's AM or FM or Sirius XM, which by the way, you know, transmits in a very, very low resolution. Oh, okay. Thanks, Phil. When MP3s became the dominant way of listening to music, a lot of casual listeners just didn't mind the trade-off. But Neil Young believed he could do better. Because he had unbelievable resources, and because he's a very, very stubborn man, he was like, I'll just do it myself.
听广播，不管是 AM、FM 还是 Sirius XM，顺便说一句，你知道的，这些广播的传输分辨率非常非常低。哦，好吧。谢谢你，菲尔。当 MP3 成为听音乐的主导方式时，许多非核心听众并不介意这种妥协。但尼尔·杨坚信他能做得更好。因为他拥有难以置信的资源，而且他又是个非常非常顽固的人，所以他当时想：我自己来做。
And that's where Pono came from. In 2012, Neil Young announced his plans for the Pono player. To give listeners a truly great experience, he devised a plan for an online store that would only sell high-quality music files. Neil said Pono files wouldn't be comparable to what you would get on a record, but they would be a lot better than an MP3. While this whole thing is pretty technical, Neil made a handy video using a nautical metaphor to explain it. When you're on the bottom of the ocean and you have a huge tank on your back and a big
这就是 Pono 的由来。2012 年，尼尔·杨宣布了他的 Pono 播放器计划。为了给听众带来真正伟大的体验，他构思了一个在线商店的计划，只出售高质量的音乐文件。尼尔说，Pono 文件比不上你在唱片上能得到的东西，但它们会比 MP3 好得多。虽然整件事情相当技术化，但尼尔用航海隐喻制作了一个便捷的视频来解释它。当你身处海底，背上背着一个巨大的气罐，头上套着一个巨大
glass ball over your head, that's kind of, you know, you're walking around in the murk and there's big fish down there. That's kind of like listening to an MP3. And when you're listening to a CD you've risen to you know maybe a couple of hundred feet below the surface something like that. And you're still underwater you're not quite in air." And according to Neil, to get to air figuratively speaking, you need some Pono. figuratively speaking, you need some Pono. With the store, listeners could buy higher quality files without going through a big tech middleman.
的玻璃球时，那种感觉，你知道的，你正行走在浑浊的水中，下面有大鱼。那种感觉就像在听 MP3。而当你听 CD 时，你已经上升到了，你知道的，距离水面大约几百英尺的地方，诸如此类。你依然在水下，还没完全呼吸到空气。”而在尼尔看来，若想呼吸到空气（比喻意义上），你需要一台 Pono。比喻意义上，你需要一台 Pono。通过这家商店，听众可以购买更高质量的文件，而无需通过大型科技中间商。
Each album would cost about 20 bucks, which was higher than iTunes, but musicians would be paid more than the pennies they were getting from Apple. Neil Young presented the whole project as a matter of principle. Pono is the Hawaiian word for righteous, which is where Neil got that from and insisted on it despite the fact that it sounds very close to porno. And in every headline, if you look at it too quickly, you might think that you're seeing a weird tech review of porn. To produce a device capable of playing these higher quality files, Neil Young had to recruit a crack team of experts, like Phil Baker, who had a distinguished career developing products at Apple and Polaroid.
每张专辑售价约 20 美元，这比 iTunes 要贵，但音乐人能拿到的报酬会比他们从苹果那里拿到的那点微薄收入要多。尼尔·杨将整个项目表现为一个原则问题。Pono 是夏威夷语中“正义”的意思，尼尔就是从这里得到了这个名字，尽管它的发音听起来非常接近“色情片”（porno），但他还是坚持使用这个名字。如果你看得太快，你在每一个标题里都可能会以为你看到的是一篇关于色情内容的奇怪科技测评。为了生产出一款能够播放这些高质量文件的设备，尼尔·杨不得不招募了一支顶尖的专家团队，比如菲尔·贝克，他在苹果和宝丽来公司开发产品有着卓越的职业生涯。
You know, the pressure was sort of on me. Everything I thought of, everything I would do, I would say, well, how does this affect Neil and his reputation? What I learned pretty quickly is that he didn't care. You know, don't worry about it. You know, you're going to try, do your best. Phil says he met with Neil Young and a small team of engineers every few weeks to discuss the project. And while Neil had total confidence in Phil and his team,
你知道的，压力有点落在我身上了。我想到的每一件事，我做的每一件事，我都会想：嗯，这对尼尔和他的声誉有什么影响？我很快了解到的是，他根本不在乎。你知道的，别担心。你知道的，去尝试，尽力而为就行。菲尔说，他每隔几周就会与尼尔·杨和一小群工程师会面一次，讨论这个项目。虽然尼尔对菲尔和他的团队充满了信心，
it was a huge task developing a music player from scratch. Apple is a machine and we were like a, you know, a tiny little animal in comparison to their jet engine. Phil says by the time he got there, the Pono team had already settled on the triangular shape for the device. While you could fit the Pono player into your hand, it was a little too big for some pockets.
但从零开始开发一款音乐播放器是一项巨大的任务。苹果是一台机器，而相比于他们的喷气发动机，我们就像一只微不足道的小动物。菲尔说，等他加入时，Pono 团队已经决定采用三角形的外形来设计这款设备。虽然你可以把 Pono 播放器握在手中，但对于某些口袋来说它稍微有点大。
But there was a very good reason for the bulkier form. Here's Nate Rogers. It was shaped like a Toblerone because it needed more space to fit the hardware and the battery in particular, because in the mid 2010s, the battery had to be larger than your average iPod battery to power hardware that was more powerful than your iPod hardware. So you just couldn't fit all of that in that space and you needed a rechargeable battery that was substantial. And so I think like the combination of those two things
但这种笨重的造型背后有非常充分的理由。这是内特·罗杰斯的话。它的形状做成三角巧克力那样，是因为它需要更多空间来容纳硬件，特别是电池，因为在 2010 年代中期，为了驱动比 iPod 硬件更强大的硬件，电池必须比普通的 iPod 电池更大。所以你根本无法把所有这些东西塞进那个空间里，你需要一个相当大的可充电电池。所以我想，这两者的结合
is where the weird shape came from. By the way, if you tell Phil Baker that it's Toblerone shaped, he will correct you. People compare it to a Toblerone bar, but in reality it was an equilateral triangle. Shape wasn't the only thing that set Pono apart from its mainstream competitor. You also couldn't go on the internet or do other things on your Pono. Another factor was the size of the screen, which was smaller than the iPod. That choice came down to cost. You know, LCDs were really tough to get that time, so we couldn't make a big flat device.
就是那个奇怪形状的由来。顺便说一句，如果你告诉菲尔·贝克它长得像三角巧克力，他会纠正你。人们把它比作一块三角巧克力，但实际上它是一个等边三角形。形状并不是让 Pono 在主流竞争对手中脱颖而出的唯一因素。你也不能在你的 Pono 上上网或做其他事情。另一个因素是屏幕的大小，它比 iPod 的还要小。这个选择归结于成本。你知道的，当时液晶显示屏很难买到，所以我们没法做一个大的扁平设备。
You could get a big screen, but they were custom, very, very expensive. And our goal was to do something that was under $300. So the display was a display that came off the back of a compact camera. After nine months of tinkering and R&D, Phil and his team finished a prototype, a yellow Toblerone or an equilateral triangle of music. And did it look funny?
你可以买到一个大屏幕，但它们是定制的，非常非常昂贵。我们的目标是做一款售价在 300 美元以下的产品。所以这个显示屏是一个小型相机背面拆下来的显示屏。经过九个月的琢磨和研发，菲尔和他的团队完成了一个原型机：一个黄色的三角巧克力或者说一个音乐的等边三角形。它看起来滑稽吗？
Yes, it did. But it also had enough space to hold a bunch of high-quality music files. And it was small enough to carry around. And it wasn't catastrophically expensive. Honestly, a pretty big win all things considered. But there was a final hurdle to getting the Pono on the market. They needed cash. Because it turns out, making an iPod killer takes a lot of money, even with a rich celebrity footing the market. They needed cash. Because it turns out making an iPod killer takes a lot of money,
是的，确实挺滑稽。但它也有足够的空间来容纳一堆高质量的音乐文件。而且它足够小，可以随身携带。它也没有贵得离谱。老实说，考虑到所有因素，这是一个相当大的胜利。但让 Pono 进入市场还有最后一个障碍。他们需要资金。因为事实证明，打造一款 iPod 杀手需要大量的资金，哪怕有富有的名人资助也是如此。他们需要资金。因为事实证明，打造一款 iPod 杀手需要大量的资金，
even with a rich celebrity footing the bill. If you look at the cost to build, let's say, 5,000 units, if it cost you even if they were $100 a piece, you know, $100 times 5,000 is half a million dollars. So just to start building units. And they started a Kickstarter campaign to try to generate enough money to set this thing off, which is a very, very difficult thing to set off any sort of digital device. To hype up the Kickstarter, Neil Young filmed a series of videos
哪怕有富有的名人买单。如果你看一下制造（比方说）5000台设备的成本，哪怕每台成本是 100 美元，你知道的，100 美元乘以 5000 就是 50 万美元。光是开始制造设备就需要这么多。于是他们发起了一场众筹活动，试图筹集足够的资金来启动这个项目，启动任何类型的数字设备都是一件非常非常困难的事情。为了炒作众筹，尼尔·杨拍摄了一系列视频，
where he showed off the prototype to his celebrity friends who raved about how much better the Pono sounded compared to the iPod. He had like a car that he would bring like backstage at shows or something like that, or drive up to Tom Petty's house. You know, all these random places in this video of Neil just like flexing on everybody by being like, I can show up to Elton John's house and just get him to listen to this because I'm Neil Young and honestly, you know, respect. It blew me away. It was like being in a recording studio.
在视频中，他向他的名人朋友们展示了原型机，他们对 Pono 相比 iPod 的音质提升赞不绝口。他好像有一辆车，他会把设备带到演出后台或者开着车去汤姆·佩蒂家之类的地方。你知道的，视频里的尼尔在所有这些随机的场合向大家秀肌肉，表现得像是在说：我可以去埃尔顿·约翰家，然后让他听听这个，因为我是尼尔·杨，老实说，你知道的，respect（致敬）。这把我震撼到了。就像身处录音室里一样。
It was like we were listening to Bob Dylan. You could hear him playing harmonica right next to you. You could hear the drums and the backing vocals on respect by Aretha. I haven't heard a sound like that since vinyl. While the video was pretty crude, Young's star power got a lot of people's attention and the Kickstarter was pretty crude, Young's star power got a lot of people's attention, and the Kickstarter was a hit. It was like the third most successful Kickstarter campaign ever at the time that they did it, so they were kind of off and running.
就像我们在听鲍勃·迪伦一样。你能听到他在你耳边吹口琴。你能听到艾瑞莎的《Respect》里的鼓声和背景和声。自从黑胶唱片以来，我再也没有听到过这样的声音了。虽然视频非常粗糙，但杨的明星光芒吸引了大量关注，众筹也大获成功。视频非常粗糙，但杨的明星光芒吸引了大量关注，众筹大获成功。在他们发起众筹时，它简直是有史以来第三成功的众筹项目，所以他们算是顺风顺水地起航了。
Well when we started the Kickstarter campaign, we basically sold about 15,000 units to Kickstarter members. I don't think we ever expected that number. While the Kickstarter hit its goal really fast, it still took about two and a half years to get the Pono to market because the development team wanted to make sure the Pono player would meet the high quality standards of true music fans. We had a handful of products that had to be had a handful of products that had to be repaired, and I mean a handful, maybe a dozen or so, out of the 15,000 products that we shipped.
当我们发起众筹活动时，我们基本上向众筹会员售出了大约 1.5 万台设备。我想我们从没预期过这个数字。虽然众筹目标很快就达到了，但 Pono 历时大约两年半才真正推向市场，因为开发团队希望确保 Pono 播放器能够达到真正的音乐发烧友的高品质标准。我们有极少数的产品需要……我们有极少数的产品需要维修，我是说极少数，在我们出货的 1.5 万件产品中，大概只有十多件。
So we were very, very lucky. After years of hype, in early 2015, the Pono was finally made available to the public. The device itself retailed for $399, about a hundred bucks more than the iPod. Thanks to the Kickstarter success, the Pono seemed to be on everybody's radar. But all of the hype might have put a target on its back, because a lot of music journalists reviewing the Pono did not like it.
所以我们非常非常幸运。经过多年的炒作，在 2015 年初，Pono 终于向公众开放购买。该设备的零售价为 399 美元，比 iPod 贵大约一百美元。多亏了众筹的成功，Pono 似乎成了每个人关注的焦点。但所有的炒作可能也让它成为了众矢之的，因为许多测评 Pono 的音乐记者并不喜欢它。
Critics slammed Pono's awkward shape and the elevated price. And some writers seemed upset the Pono's awkward shape and the elevated price, and some writers seemed to upset the Pono existed at all. Slate Magazine called the whole thing a vanity project. Many reviews called out Pono for carrying fewer songs than other music players. Essentially, to use the Pono, a lot of people would have to pick and choose which albums you wanted on there at any given time. Maybe you'd be able to fit 10 or 20.
评论家们猛烈抨击 Pono 尴尬的形状和高昂的价格。有些作家似乎对 Pono 尴尬的形状和高昂的价格感到不满，还有些作家甚至对 Pono 的存在本身感到恼火。《Slate》杂志称整个项目为一个虚荣项目。许多评论指出 Pono 容纳的歌曲比其他音乐播放器少。从本质上讲，为了使用 Pono，很多人必须在任何特定时间挑选他们想放在上面的专辑。也许你只能放 10 张或 20 张。
And you would choose which ones on any given day, you know, you'd want to go take with you. There was a sense the knives were out for Pono. Which in hindsight isn't a big surprise. I mean, come on, Neil Young named the product after the Hawaiian word for righteous. And as Stereophiles John Atkinson points out, there's a particular disdain reserved for music nerds, especially those who try to make you buy expensive, high-tech gear. Ex-stereophile writer Michael Fremer wrote about this some years ago.
你可以在任何特定的一天挑选你想随身携带的专辑。有一种“人人喊打”的感觉。现在回想起来，这并不令人意外。我是说，拜托，尼尔·杨竟然用夏威夷语的“正义”来命名这个产品。正如《Stereophile》的约翰·阿特金森所指出的那样，人们对音乐极客有一种特殊的蔑视，尤其是那些试图让你购买昂贵的高科技装备的极客。前《Stereophile》撰稿人迈克尔·弗雷默几年前曾写过关于这方面的文章。
But he said, you know, you read the many critics who targeted Pono for its sound quality. Some critics argued the music experience on the Pono player was somehow worse than on an iPhone. Even though Pono files were objectively larger and higher fidelity, some reviews said that you couldn't tell the difference between the Pono and the iPod, especially when they played it for other people. One critic named David Pogue went so far as to set up A-B testing. With average people comparing Pono and Pono grade files and iPod and iPod grade files.
但他说，你知道的，你读到许多批评家将 Pono 作为音质靶子。一些批评家认为，Pono 播放器上的音乐体验不知为何甚至比 iPhone 上还要糟糕。尽管 Pono 文件客观上更大、保真度更高，但一些评论称，你根本听不出 Pono 和 iPod 之间的区别，特别是当他们把它放给其他人听的时候。一位名叫大卫·波格的评论家甚至进行了 A-B 测试。让普通人对比 Pono 和 Pono 级音质文件以及 iPod 和 iPod 级音质文件。
And he also used over-ear headphones and he used earbuds. And his group of people that he chose pretty clearly chose the iPod over the Pono no matter which combination of things he did. According to David Pogue, testers could not spot the difference, whether they were listening on tinny earbuds or over plush expensive headphones. It might sound surprising that a higher quality audio file
他还使用了头戴式耳机和耳塞。他所选择的那群人在无论他进行哪种组合测试时，都非常明确地选择了 iPod 而不是 Pono。根据大卫·波格的说法，无论测试者是戴着单薄的耳塞还是昂贵奢华的头戴式耳机，他们都无法分辨出区别。更高质量的音频文件
actually sounds worse to most listeners, but most people just picked what they were most familiar with. It's kind of like how most people, people like me, can't really tell the difference between a $20 bottle of wine and an $80 bottle of wine. In the end, it all just tastes like wine. It's really hard to use a part of your brain that's not activated when you listen to music bottle of wine. In the end, it all just tastes like wine.
对大多数听众来说听起来反而更糟糕，这听起来可能令人惊讶，但大多数人只是选择了他们最熟悉的东西。这有点像大多数人（比如我）根本分不清 20 美元的葡萄酒和 80 美元的葡萄酒有什么区别。到头来，它们尝起来都只是葡萄酒。当你听音乐时，要调动大脑中那些平时不活跃的区域真的很难。20 美元的葡萄酒。到头来，它们尝起来都只是葡萄酒。
The bad reviews didn't help, but they weren't fatal. In the end, Pono was a victim of timing. Pono kind of hit the market at the absolute worst time. When it was conceived in 2012, Apple sold 35 million iPods. But by 2014, sales were way down, and Apple actually discontinued the iPod Classic. The iPod was made obsolete by the iPhone, which could play music, but also make phone calls and surf the internet and do all the other stupid things we do on our phones. The idea of a single-use MP3 player was totally outdated.
差评并没有帮忙，但也并非致命。归根结底，Pono 是时机的牺牲品。Pono 进入市场的时机绝对糟透了。当它在 2012 年被构思出来时，苹果售出了 3500 万台 iPod。但到 2014 年，销量大幅下滑，苹果甚至停产了 iPod Classic。iPod 被 iPhone 淘汰了，iPhone 不仅能播放音乐，还能打电话、上网，以及做我们在手机上做的所有其他蠢事。单一功能的 MP3 播放器这个概念已经完全过时了。
Not only that, downloading MP3s became totally outdated too, because of the rise of streaming music. Streaming was the new thing, and it was the future. And there was no world in which you could convince people to buy a really bulky, pretty expensive MP3 player. In 2015, services like Spotify exploded in popularity, and rivals like Apple Music offered an entire world of sound for $10 a month. That's about half of what it cost to get a popular new record in the Pono store.
不仅如此，随着流媒体音乐的兴起，下载 MP3 也彻底过时了。流媒体是新事物，它代表着未来。在这个世界上，你绝对无法说服人们去买一个既笨重又相当昂贵的 MP3 播放器。2015 年，像 Spotify 这样的服务呈爆炸式增长，而像 Apple Music 这样的竞争对手则以每月 10 美元的价格提供了一个完整的音乐世界。这大约是在 Pono 商店购买一张流行新专辑所需费用的一半。
Just to really add insult to injury, one of the big tech giants made it really hard to get new music for the Pono. In 2016, Apple bought the company that ran the Pono store and put them out of business. You know, at the time we looked at transferring all the work we did, there weren't very few companies developing music stores, but we talked to others, and it was just too expensive
更雪上加霜的是，其中一家科技巨头让 Pono 很难获取新音乐。2016 年，苹果收购了运营 Pono 商店的公司，并使其倒闭。你知道的，当时我们考虑过转移我们所做的一切工作，当时几乎没有什么公司在开发音乐商店，但我们和别人谈过，这实在是太贵了
and too complex. We didn't have the resources to really start over again and create another store. The Pono team tried hanging on for a little while, but in 2017, Young announced they were winding down the project. While numbers were never made public, it's believed Neil Young lost a lot of money on the Pono. And while some people might be embarrassed by all this, Phil Baker says Neil took it in stride.
也太复杂了。我们没有资源从头开始再创建一个商店。Pono 团队试图坚持一小段时间，但在 2017 年，杨宣布他们正在逐步关闭该项目。虽然具体数字从未公开，但据信尼尔·杨在 Pono 上损失了巨额资金。虽然有些人可能会对这一切感到尴尬，但菲尔·贝克说尼尔泰然处之。
We weren't having the great success. I figured, well, Neil is going to be upset. He probably doesn't want is going to be upset. He probably doesn't want to talk to me anymore. What I found was so surprising. He just was, you know, very matter of fact about it. Like, you know, this record didn't end up number one, maybe my next record will or something like that.
我们没有取得巨大的成功。我想，好吧，尼尔一定会很沮丧。他可能不想再和我说话了。但我发现的情况却大为出乎意料。他对此非常务实。就像是，你知道的，这张唱片最后没能排到第一名，也许我的下一张唱片会，诸如此类。
He was very normal, I guess I would say. It's been about a decade now since Pono's rise and fall. And as a casual Neil Young fan, I'd always just thought of it as some footnote in his incredible career. But when I read Nate Rogers' article, I took a step back and considered maybe there's more to the Pono than its goofy reputation. Because the Pono, it kind of looks prophetic when you consider just how much things have changed about our relationship to music. In the past 10 years, we have devalued music in lots of ways. In the 90s, artists could make a pretty good living off CD sales.
我想我会说他非常正常。自 Pono 的兴衰起落以来，大约已经过去十年了。作为尼尔·杨的普通粉丝，我一直把它当作他不可思议的职业生涯中的一个脚注。但当我读到内特·罗杰斯的文章时，我退后一步思考：也许 Pono 的意义不仅限于它那滑稽的名声。因为当你考虑到我们与音乐的关系发生了多大变化时，Pono 看起来简直具有预言性。在过去 10 年里，我们在很多方面贬低了音乐的价值。在 90 年代，艺术家靠 CD 销量就能过上相当不错的生活。
Then, with iTunes, they made a less good living selling mp3s. Today on Spotify, musicians generally receive one third of a cent every time their song is played. The Pono was trying to stand for something. For high quality and respect for artists. But instead, as music fans, we've chosen a different path. One of convenience and low prices. Sure, the Pono store selling a high-quality album for $20
后来，有了 iTunes，他们靠卖 MP3 只能过上不太好的生活。如今在 Spotify 上，音乐人每次播放歌曲通常只能拿到三分之一美分。Pono 曾试图捍卫某些价值。为了高品质和对艺术家的尊重。但相反，作为音乐爱好者，我们选择了一条不同的道路。一条追求便利和低价的道路。当然，Pono 商店以 20 美元的价格出售高质量专辑
seems really expensive by today's standards, but now lots of musicians can't make ends meet. Maybe we need to spend $20 once in a while. And the devaluation of music isn't just financial. There's also the matter of appreciation. There's also the matter of appreciation. So much of what shaped my music listening experience was buying records that I decided I was going to get my money's worth and being like, I value this because I bought it and I'm going to spend time with it and get to know it. And Pono's whole approach was music fidelity, but it's also just it's a broader element of like active participation when people
以今天的标准来看似乎真的很贵，但现在许多音乐人却无法维持生计。也许我们偶尔也需要花上 20 美元。音乐的贬值不仅是财务上的。还有一个欣赏的问题。还有一个欣赏的问题。塑造我音乐聆听体验的很大一部分原因在于购买唱片，我决定要物超所值，并觉得：我买了这个，所以我珍视它，我要花时间陪伴它、了解它。而 Pono 的整体方法是音乐保真度，但它其实也是一种更广泛的主动参与的元素，当人们
just have thousands and thousands of songs at their fingertip it diminishes your relationship to the music If you want to experience Neil Young's dream for the Pono, maybe you don't need that yellow triangular music player It might be enough to spend a little more time with art. Just linger in front of a painting at a museum. Or read a book at a coffee shop with your phone in your pocket. Or just listen to a record, while doing nothing else. And let the music in. There is a way to hear higher quality music in this dreaming age, and we will tell you about it after this. So we are back with Chris Berube.
只需动动手指就能拥有成千上万首歌曲时，它削弱了你与音乐的关系如果你想体验尼尔·杨对 Pono 的梦想，也许你并不需要那个黄色的三角形音乐播放器花更多时间与艺术相伴可能就足够了。比如在博物馆的一幅画前多驻足一会儿。或者在咖啡馆里把手机揣在口袋里读一本书。或者只是单纯地听一张唱片，什么也不做。让音乐走入内心。在这个梦想的时代，有一种方法可以听到更高质量的音乐，我们将在广告之后告诉你。所以我们回到了克里斯·贝鲁比这里。
Hey Chris. Hey Roman. So we've been talking about the listening experience of the Pono and I was wondering, did you get a chance to actually listen to one? Roman, I tried. I tried so hard. I asked lots of people how to get a hold of one. I ordered one on eBay and the seller sent me a message saying,
嘿，克里斯。嘿，罗曼。所以我们一直在讨论 Pono 的聆听体验，我想知道，你真的有机会听过一台吗？罗曼，我试过了。我拼命地试过。我问了很多人怎么才能弄到一台。我在 eBay 上订购了一台，然后卖家给我发了一条消息说：
this item doesn't exist. Sorry about this. I've never seen that before. Like I've never tried to buy an item on eBay and they're like, we actually don't. This isn't a real thing. I'm not sure what happened with that. And actually most of the ones on eBay, there are a few for sale on eBay. Most of them are just there for spare parts. So you could buy it to fix problems with your existing Pono, but there are not a lot of for spare parts. So you could buy it to fix problems with your existing Pono, but there are not a lot of new Ponos that you could buy through that.
这件商品不存在。对此感到抱歉。我以前从没见过这种情况。就像我从来没有在 eBay 上买过一件商品，然后他们说：其实我们没有。这不是个真实的东西。我不太确定那是怎么回事。事实上，eBay 上的大多数商品（eBay 上有几个在售商品）其实都只是当作备件出售的。所以你可以买它来修复你现有 Pono 的问题，但你买不到很多用来当备件的……你可以买它来修复你现有 Pono 的问题，但你买不到很多全新的 Pono。
Well, that is too bad. And actually kind of weird that there hasn't been one that's like filtered into the secondary market at all. I know, it's just they're impossible to find. And actually Nate Rogers, who wrote the piece for Stereogum that was the basis for all of this, he tried to get one for his story, no luck on that. But I do have some good news, which is that there is a substitute that tries to recreate
好吧，那太遗憾了。而且说实话，居然没有哪怕一台流入二手市场，这也挺奇怪的。我知道，它们简直是不可能找到。事实上，为《Stereogum》撰写本文基础文章的内特·罗杰斯，为了他的报道也尝试搞到一台，但没能如愿。不过我确实有好消息，那就是有一个替代品试图重现
the experience of hearing music on the Pono. Okay, how does that work? So there is a website called the Neil Young Archives, and actually Phil Baker works on this project. So after Pono, Phil kept collaborating with Neil Young, and he helped to put together this website. It's kind of actually laid out like an archive. Like it's a really fun bit of design, the website.
在 Pono 上听音乐的体验。好吧，那是怎么运作的？有一个名为“尼尔·杨档案馆”的网站，事实上菲尔·贝克也参与了这个项目。所以在 Pono 之后，菲尔继续与尼尔·杨合作，并协助搭建了这个网站。它的布局其实真的就像一个档案馆。网站的设计非常有趣，
Like you go on there, it looks like you're entering a filing cabinet. And then you go through and there's just all of this arcana for Neil Young. The Neil Young Archives is really a depository of everything you would find in a real archive. Handwritten notes, photographs of objects, lyrics, timelines, you know, it's just a wealth of information. So you get basically all of these DVD extras of Neil Young's career and life. And on top of all that, it has all of Neil's music streaming in high resolution. So they're trying to do something that is similar to what you would hear on the Pono.
比如你上去之后，感觉就像是走进了一个文件柜。然后你浏览进去，里面全都是关于尼尔·杨的各种秘辛。“尼尔·杨档案馆”真的就像是一个储藏库，存放着你在真正的档案馆里能找到的一切。手稿、实物照片、歌词、时间轴，你知道的，这里面有着丰富的财富。所以你基本上可以获得关于尼尔·杨职业生涯和生活的所有这些 DVD 花絮。最棒的是，它拥有尼尔所有以高分辨率流式传输的音乐。所以他们试图做一些类似于你在 Pono 上能听到的事情。
And Phil actually sent me a subscription to check it out. So I got to listen to that for a while. So did you notice a difference between what you could sort of get in the Neil Young archive versus what you could hear on Spotify or something like that? I got to be honest from it. I came into this being so skeptical. Like this whole story, even after doing this whole story, I was still kind of like, how big of a difference could it be? And I put it on and just immediately I was like,
菲尔实际上给我寄了一个订阅账号让我去体验一下。所以我听了一段时间。那你有没有注意到，你在“尼尔·杨档案馆”里能听到的东西，和你在 Spotify 之类的地方听到的东西有什么区别？老实说，罗曼。我带着极度的怀疑态度开始接触这个。就像整个故事，甚至在完成这个报道之后，我心里还是在想：音质能有多大区别呢？当我把它打开时，我立刻就觉得：
oh, that sounds better. That actually sounds quite a bit better. And then I listed a couple of Neil Young songs on Spotify, switched over, listened to the same ones on the archives, and I could really hear like these little differences. Like you could hear the harmonica trailing off, like kind of these little things that we talk about in the story.
哦，这个听起来更好。这听起来确实要好得多。然后我在 Spotify 上听了几首尼尔·杨的歌，切换过去，在档案馆里听同一首歌，我真的能听到这些小小的区别。比如你能听到口琴声音的渐渐消逝，就像我们在故事里讨论的那些微小细节。
Now, I should say, I was primed to listen for that kind of thing after working on the story for so long. So take it with a grain of salt. I might have been set up to believe this. But no, I really did notice a difference. That's really interesting. But this is just for Neil Young's music, right?
现在，我必须说明的是，在做了这么长时间的报道之后，我对聆听这类东西已经有了心理预期。所以大家听听就好，持保留态度。我可能已经被预设去相信这一点了。但说真的，我确实注意到了区别。这真的很有意思。但这仅限于尼尔·杨的音乐，对吧？
Like there isn't other music that you can try out. That's right. So it's not like a total recreation of the Pono experience because all you can get is Neil Young's archive on there. But I think a lot of people don't know this actually. You actually can access higher resolution music on a lot of streaming services. Did you know about this, Roman? I remember that being a selling point of Tidal. I don't know if Tidal still exists, but that's the only one I've really heard of. Yeah, so Tidal does still exist. You can still listen in higher resolution.
就像没有其他音乐你可以去尝试。没错。所以它并不完全是对 Pono 体验的复刻，因为你在上面只能获得尼尔·杨的档案馆。但我想很多人其实并不知道这一点。你其实可以在很多流媒体服务上获取更高分辨率的音乐。你知道这个吗，罗曼？我记得那是 Tidal 的卖点。我不知道 Tidal 是不是还存在，但那是我唯一听说过的。对的，所以 Tidal 仍然存在。你依然可以收听更高分辨率的音频。
And actually Apple Music also has a tier where you can listen at a higher resolution. Spotify, it should be noted, they have pretty limited options in terms of fidelity. You can turn it up. The default is actually a pretty low resolution MP3. So you can turn it up. The default is actually a pretty low resolution MP3. So you can turn it up to the point that it kind of sounds closer to CD quality.
事实上，Apple Music 也提供可以收听更高分辨率的档位。需要指出的是，就音质而言，Spotify 的选项非常有限。你可以把它调高。默认设置其实是一个相当低分辨率的 MP3。所以你可以把它调高。默认设置其实是一个相当低分辨率的 MP3。所以你可以把它调高到听起来更接近 CD 音质的程度。
There's actually one service called QOBUZ. So Qobuz, I'm not sure how to pronounce it. Their whole deal is just offering things in higher resolution. And I tried all of these, actually, and all of them, like, yeah, I could notice a bit of a difference. Like they all sounded quite a bit better. So there are options out there.
实际上有一项名为 QOBUZ 的服务。所以是 Qobuz，我不太确定怎么发音。他们的全部业务就是提供更高分辨率的内容。事实上，我把这些都试了一遍，所有这些服务，是的，我确实能注意到一点区别。它们听起来都好多了。所以市面上的选择还是有的。
And in a way, talking to Nate Rogers about this, he was telling me like, this kind of feels like a vindication of the Pono, right? This idea that higher resolution audio is something that is now more normal. I almost feel like Neil cared less about his device and more about the conversation and that he wanted people to start thinking about it
某种程度上，和内特·罗杰斯谈论这件事时，他告诉我，这感觉有点像对 Pono 的一种平反，对吧？这种观点认为，更高分辨率的音频现在正变得更加正常。我甚至觉得，尼尔关心的与其说是他的设备，不如说是这场对话，他希望人们开始思考这个问题，
and start asking for more out of the tech companies that had taken charge of music in the 21st century. And if you really want this conversation to continue, I'm sure there are corners of the internet in which it is happening right now. This conversation is happening at length about every format of music and which is better and how to listen in a perfect environment. This just seems like what the internet was made for. Oh, truly endless, especially like Stereophile,
并开始向那些在 21 世纪掌控了音乐的科技公司提出更高要求。如果你真的希望这场对话继续下去，我确信互联网的某些角落里现在正在发生这种讨论。关于每一种音乐格式、哪一种更好以及如何在完美环境中聆听的讨论正在深入进行。这看起来简直就是为互联网量身打造的。哦，真的是无穷无尽，尤其是像《Stereophile》
the community around Stereophile magazine. I went on a couple of the forums about the listening quality for Series XM, for example, and there is so much back and forth rum, and you could waste entire days on that. Well, the story's been so fun for us. I really appreciate you bringing us the Pono. I'm glad we can keep the legend of the Pono alive. Thank you for this. A lot of fun.
《Stereophile》杂志周边的社区。我浏览了一些关于 Sirius XM 聆听质量等方面的论坛，里面有那么多的争论，罗曼，你可以在上面浪费整整几天。好吧，这个报道对我们来说太有趣了。非常感谢你把 Pono 带给我们。我很高兴我们能让 Pono 的传奇延续下去。谢谢你带来这一切。非常有趣。
99% of this vote was produced this week by Chris Berube edited by Kelly Prime fact-checking by Lara Bollins mixed by Martin Gonzalez music by Swan Real. Today's episode is based on Nate Rogers reporting about the Pono for Stereogum magazine. Nate's piece is great. It gets a lot more detailed than we could. We will include a link to Nate's article at 99pi.org. Special thanks this week to Stereogum, Kate Mishkin, and Myron Kaplan. Our executive producer is Kathy Tu. Our senior editor is Delaney Hall.
本周的 99% Invisible 由克里斯·贝鲁比制作，凯利·普莱姆剪辑，拉拉·博林斯核实事实，马丁·加利桑克斯混音，天鹅真实乐队（Swan Real）配乐。今天的节目基于内特·罗杰斯为《Stereophile》杂志关于 Pono 的报道。内特的文章非常棒。它比我们所能涉及的要详细得多。我们将在 99pi.org 上附上内特文章的链接。本周特别感谢《Stereophile》、凯特·米什金和迈伦·卡普兰。我们的执行制作人是凯西·图。我们的资深编辑是德兰尼·霍尔。
Our digital director is Kurt Kohlstedt. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Ley, Lasha Madon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% Invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM Podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora Building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. You'll find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯特德。其余团队成员包括杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·莱、拉莎·马顿、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、乔·罗森伯格以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。99% Invisible 的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们是 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，在潘多拉大楼向北六个街区处。你可以在 Blue Sky 以及我们自己的 Discord 服务器上找到我们。你可以在 99pi.org 上找到通往该链接以及 99PI 每一期往期节目的链接。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。